i'm not gonna name the person because  it's embarrassing okay  the point is we're doing a stunt in  front of hugh jackman now i have very  few scenes with hugh jackman and um i  was very i was very nervous it was not  you  so we're doing this this this this thing  where i'm basically up in the air and i  spin down and i get caught and i heard a  fart  it was not me  i just want to clarify right here right  now is not me so they're laughing the  other person  okay is laughing and he was laughing i'm  like okay are we just gonna like pretend  like it didn't happen are we gonna like  laugh about it  and what happened was the person  who was a grown man blamed it on me  no one thought that wasn't you no one  let me tell you something yeah if i ever  farted in front of you yeah it would  definitely be silent but deadly  never audibly never audibly you know  what i'm saying i'm a lady